[Music]
okay so this is my review of nine
perfect strangers finale like last week
i'm going off the cuff here because
screeners weren't sent out for these
last two episodes so i'm gonna do my
best just to riff here i just watched it
like you guys so
i'm actually
have a lot of mixed feelings about this
finale but i'm actually
more impressed than i thought i would be
it's like a little bit of a surprise
and
it's one of those effects where it's the
finale maybe it's not super satisfying
for the season as a whole i didn't think
that was gonna happen
i think this show you can divide right
down the middle and characters and see
that
certain group got the attention they
needed and it actually ended really well
especially just the emotional aspect of
it and getting our payoffs for that and
what we've put into these characters and
there's another side where it didn't
land at all and some characters just got
completely forgotten at the end of the
day i think you can clearly see that the
main story here is of masha and the
marconis
it
in the middle of the season was mostly
francis and tony but if you really look
at francis and tony's story that story
kind of
wrapped itself
you know two episodes ago and they kind
of just tried extending it by bringing
up her kind of saying something mean to
him in the sauna so it was kind of just
redundant a bit with them here
it already ended on a good close so that
store is kind of over for me but what i
pointed out is that you know jessica and
ben's characters just completely got off
the main script here like they were just
forgotten about and
they didn't really get anything more
here in the finale
i think it's nice touch that they're the
ones who are gonna run tranquilium but
that
just storyline made me feel like they
shouldn't even been in the show maybe
they should have taken a liberty here
and cut them out of the show if they
were going to give them really any like
meat to their story which was weird
because they did start to get some in
the beginning and it just faded out i
also think we got
no
you know i still don't know yeah i i
don't know this man any more than i did
when i first saw him on the screen
uh that was a problem for me and i think
they also really faded out of delilah
because they had this love triangle of
yao delilah and masha and they kind of
skimped over that and delilah just
became this character driving the car to
be a plot device to go get the cops at
the end of the day which maybe that
should have been somebody else like that
side character like glory like why waste
delilah who we already had some
emotional you know investment in so she
kind of got really just thrown away here
too so
that would be my group that was really
disappointing um where i think they
really landed it well is with masha
herself
i think
that it really did work here and her
having her moment with her daughter
through the marconis which she wanted i
like that she ended up having the cops
they ended up having the cops come on
her but that
you know end of the day everyone
believed in her cause and that you know
they she had good intention even when
they made you think she was actually
trapping these people in a room and
setting on fire but it's just a practice
they have for everyone to have a
near-death experience but
what is interesting is that like why
didn't they do those practices when they
first came same with the
uh sensory deprivation tank for carmel
because it seems like they're the two
most effective practices you you wonder
why did they just do that when they got
to a resort i think we would have
avoided a lot of the trouble here but
um i think of course like i've said
regina hall incredible here um i think
the marconi story got so much weight to
it and it did get a really good close
they got what they hyped up where they
would have this like you know joint
hallucination of the sun and they'd get
their closure as masha does and it's all
through each other here now where i did
get like a little annoyed at the realism
of it was one moment in particular when
zoe
gets the snowflake right because
at the end of the day hallucinating but
there's no way
her
character would envision that snowflake
attach it to masha in her head without
having any knowledge of that like where
would she have come up with that to see
that so that felt a little bit of a
cheat for me that was stretching too
much but otherwise i did like the
sequences here and i'm really blown away
by jonathan levine's directing with how
he shoots all this visually and really
gets you in the mode of these people
tripping out and it was fascinating
visually to watch this episode and it
was his best stuff his best directing um
but
you know
i think there's
points of disappointment like
i was right that it was carmel it wasn't
a hallucination that masha was having
that carmel did shoot her but to have
the twist that carmel also was the one
leaving
you know the messages and writing all
this crazy stuff in the wall was like
really like
that's obviously the most obvious choice
when we found out you know that
masha was sleeping with her husband so
i didn't like that that made like why
did you give so much time then to that
little side story if someone's
threatening her if it was just going to
be carmel who we've kind of already been
given now as the obvious point so you
made it the obvious point in finale
which is always going to feel like a
disappointment so that was disappointing
um i do also think
that
i'm so so about how they wrapped
carmel's story where it might have
actually felt a little rushed her
transformation at the end to see her in
this like recovery meeting and talking
about forgiveness when i would have
liked one more moment at least
with carmel and masha at the end there
when masha was leaving for the cops she
made like a little headnod but she had
time to talk to zoey there but maybe a
little dialogue with carmel because it
was so important that character
relationship at the beginning of this
episode and we really only got to see it
end with masha you know
sedating carmel so
that was a little bit of a letdown um
but
i think
it was mostly good i think that
you know
i
will take away performance wise from the
show that
everyone did an amazing job here and i
think really though the standout still
has to be regina hall
to get an emmy to actually win an emmy
here and i think that michael shannon
and bobby canavallie should be nominated
everyone else they're really good but
those are the standouts and i've seen a
lot of people harder nicole kidman's
performance here i don't think it's one
of her best but i still think it's
really good and i thought this was her
best episode clearly especially when she
has a little monologue to everyone when
they first start hallucinating about her
daughter and what she's been doing i
thought that was really good she did a
good way to get you to like masha here
and
i think the marconi is the whole family
everybody here greg's fam patton shout
out to her i haven't talked about her
enough you checked out an interview i
did with her you know a couple of months
ago on my channel she's really cool
person but she did a really good job
and
you know i'm also going to say besides
performances with hai other show which
was expected you know
the visuals the cinematography the
directing really good
the only thing that really like again
was disappointing was this writing here
i think they wrote so much good
character work with the plot at the
other day wasn't that interesting um and
that
also i'm saying good character work but
they skimmed out a lot of people which
was surprising like they had all these
storylines set up with characters and
then they just kind of
forgot about them and didn't give way
they just made cuts here like ah you
know what let's not keep going into
delilah and yao's relationship let's not
keep going into allah's relationship
with
masha let's just forget about jessica
and ben and make them just goofy and
fall in love so
that's where it fell flat for me um
i think that you know
i enjoyed the finale but i wasn't like
crying where i should have maybe i felt
a little emotions but that's just me so
that also you know as that's from the
whole season as a whole i don't know if
i cared enough here but it's interesting
that where people were expecting it to
go haywire
they're kind of showing you that masha's
plan did work but also if you look at it
you know in hindsight it's also kind of
silly because you're just like what
about the connollies what about the guy
where he died because of this you know
it's kind of like yeah he was he was the
test dummy you know at least to work
with the marconis and everyone's happy
you know so
that kind of felt a little silly
um but you know i think
you can think however you want about
what the show's saying about
hallucinogenics and what it might bring
for the future people doing with their
trauma but they did a good job of
showing how it worked here and how it
gave these people their closure for all
their trauma and you know i i thought
they did a good job with that and i i
felt closure with the marconis as i do
with masha's story which was super
important because they were the main
characters here
uh but you know it was always gonna be
hard because it's like an avengers cast
your nine perfect stranger so to get
everybody's mouths fed and feel like
every story satisfied really wasn't the
case and like i said i just wish they
had some really good last scene with
carmel
and
masha which we didn't really get but
again i think what i'll remember from
the show the most is regina hall's
performance at the end of the day
especially here when she's like freaking
out and every time claustrophobic just
really really remarkable remarkable
stuff i'm blown away by it so um yeah i
mean i'm gonna give this finale an 8.8
one of the stronger episodes for sure
and i am going to give the season as a
whole with all my ratings i would say
you know
i would say 8.1
you know i still think it's a little
disappointing from what the talent we
have here behind it and on the screen
but
you know
at the end of the day they're not all
going to be hits they're not going to be
amazing but it wasn't bad it could have
been horrible too so
i'm happy about it but i'm ready to move
on you know uh so that's how i feel but
i want to know your guys thoughts please
let me know your season score and your
rating of this episode and please please
subscribe i really appreciate it helps
me in so many ways it'll open more doors
for me i can do more videos for you guys
that way
you have no idea just hitting that
subscribe button helps so much and if
you really like what i do
hitting that join button down below
becoming a member just donating you get
perks but it'll help me do this you know
more for you guys do more reviews do
more interviews i really appreciate it i
appreciate every single one of you don't
think i know i notice literally every
single comment i try to respond as many
as i can so write it down below and yeah
follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram and now tick tock as
well you get more little reviews from me
little graphics and interview clips so
please check that out and i'll see you
next time